morning I'm going to start by inviting
you to introduce yourselves I'm going to
start on my on my right hand side Nigel
thank you good morning my name is Nigel
Torrington I am the chief executive of
paragon banking group I'm also a board
representative of UK Finance
uh good morning my name is Brad Fordham
I'm the mortgage director for Santander
UK
morning Charlotte Harris
the trim CEO of home financing for
Skipton Building Society
Sam homes director at Lloyd's Banker
group
this morning Henry Jordan commercial
director for home at Nationwide
thank you and um obviously as part of my
workers chair Outreach I have had a
dinner with the building societies
Association
um I think last week and I think it was
a representative from Nationwide then
I'm not sure anyone's there from from
Skipton but I'll just set that out for
the record
um in terms of uh initial questions to
each one of you uh it's obviously been a
long period where a lot of your
customers have enjoyed very low rates on
their mortgages and now have seen very
very sharp increases in mortgage rates
can you share with the committee what
you're seeing in terms of the reaction
from those borrowers affected and how
that's affecting the quality of your
mortgage book pointing out any increases
you may be seeing in arrears uh there
are a number of accounts that you have
in forbearance and whether you're seeing
a sharp increase in terms of any
repossessions and I'll start this time
with Henry
um so yes agree that there is a
significant increase in rates for
customers maturing off their original
product as contacts for our mortgage
book it's around a 235 pounds per month
increase
um that's roughly about a third a third
increase in their payment
um
that said we haven't really seen any
real material movement in our area's
performance
um certainly within our Prime uh
residential portfolio uh areas are are
stable we've seen a roughly a
one basis point increase in arrears over
the past 12 months that's on a three
down a three months in arrears measure
we have seen a slight a slightly higher
increase in earlier years particularly
on the buy to let book mainly because
um
those customers are predominantly on
interest only already and therefore have
fewer options available to them in terms
of forbearance that's actually down
slightly year on year so I think
customers are generally taking action
um that we have seen an increase in
overpayments we've seen an increase in
turn extensions
um
but no material increase in in Arizona
Nationwide has
the market share as does Lloyd's do you
recognize the picture that we just heard
there from Henry what do you seeing
because UK Finance data for the first
quarter of uh of this year did show a
tick up in terms of mortgage arrears
what are you seeing they're very similar
to Nationwide so undoubtedly households
and customers are feeling the
uh effect of not just mortgage rates
increasing but the wider cost of living
crisis but as we look at the impact on
arrays and forbearance and repossessions
very similar to Henry's or uptick but
arrays remain very low in a historical
context and still below what we'd have
seen pre-covered
the tail so
in terms of the trend for customers
percentage of customers that are in
areas that remains flat year on year we
haven't seen any uplift and just
referring to your point on UK Finance
data and q1c in a small uplift I think
what we've seen is some seasonality and
Trends in a customers entering areas so
we did see a modest increase in q1 areas
that have actually come back down since
then so some of those factors sometimes
around seasonality of holiday and season
Christmas period and we tend to see an
uplift in January we also had um the
shorter April month bank holiday and so
some of those factors will play into
um areas performance but actually the
trend over the longer term is that we've
seen small uplift and then and that
trend has come back down
very interesting Santander so very
similar picture
um a small tick up in arrears
um still 20 below pre-pandemic 70 below
um 2009 post financial crisis so
relatively low levels
um similarly in terms of payment
increases for customers customers
typically coming off 2.3 and this year
going on to an average rate of around
four and a half percent with a payment
increase of over 200 pounds per month
obviously as high as interest rates
increase then that payment increase
could can increase so it's a broadly
similar picture I think one thing just
to probably point out is
um over the last 10 or 12 years and
certainly for us at Santander 95 of the
customers that have joined us as
mortgage customers we have stressed
their affordability and understood can
they afford the mortgage payment today
but also in the future so so we've
affordability stress tests at a higher
interest rate typically in the market
that may have been over recent years
around six percent so so at the time of
application or stress at the time of
application
um you know we've understood that
customers can can bear a higher interest
rate and that seems to be bearing out at
this at this moment in time
that's very interesting now in terms of
paragon your business mainly uh buy to
let
um is there a portion of your business
that's not by to let that you'd want to
comment on in the context of what you've
heard your colleagues say the business
that we don't do that's buy to let will
be we are quite active in financing
house builders uh also small businesses
as well uh our comment and observation
there is actually we're seeing a very
stable arrears positions across all of
those portfolios
in terms of you'd like me to comment
about buy to let specifically
um I think we'll get to some more
detailed questions on on by to let as we
go go down and and that's very
interesting we're also doing an inquiry
on small business lending so it's
interesting to hear your evidence on
that but if I can now start asking the
question so in a in a slightly different
way which is around the provisioning
that you're likely to put in place in
terms of your loan losses uh this year
so we're coming up to the reporting of
second quarter results I appreciate you
know you won't be able to share uh
anything that's not out there in the
public domain but are you are you going
to be provisioning uh to reflect what
you've just told us about the quality of
your mortgage book Bradley so I don't
have specific numbers to hand of course
we're in a closed period currently we
would expect Provisions to rise very
slightly in line with arrears as the
customers move into different stages for
reporting purposes so we'd expect a
small increase but I don't have those
but happily of course can share with the
committee in writing once those figures
are available thank you Charlotte
I would Echo and Bradley's comments so I
think provisioning will reflect the
quality of our book and again would
expect a small increase in that
um but it's reflected off and the
position of various performance today
okay and Andrew
we report in two weeks time so it was in
a close period but similarly the
provision will reflect the underlying
quality and arrays that we're seeing in
the fairly
Nationwide
yeah I can provide a bit more detail I
should have said like Santander are
arrays rates are remain below
pre-pandemic levels so we haven't really
seen a material movement in in arrears
and we have applied some model
adjustments to reflect
um Borough affordability impacts which
did increase our provision in our
four-year results which are published in
April our provision coverage ratios is
0.14 that's more skewed towards buy to
let than residential okay
of the year it's been reported that
there are a lot of people who took out
two-year fixed rates and that those will
be coming to an end and they took out
those two-year fixed rates when there
was the Stamp Duty holiday uh to uh
reflect the pandemic conditions and do
you model what you've got upcoming and
do you think that
you've painted us to for us today is
going to change markedly if we see you
again in six months time
who wants to start with that one
I'm happy to to start so
um I think there's a few um there's a
few drivers around the performance of
book and for customers entering
financial difficulty so Bradley's
touched on some of them which is around
and we stress test customers at a higher
interest rate environment so we stretch
affordability in that assessment to
ensure that we're future proofing to as
much as we can that the customers can
maintain and afford those repayments
we also know that for customers and that
will mature this year whether right now
that's from a two-year fixed period or a
five-year fixed period they've been for
the most part in making Capital
repayments against that so the balance
will have been reducing over time
and we also know that we've just come
out of double-digit house price growth
and and therefore whilst those customers
have been uh repaying the capital
balances on their mortgages they've also
benefited from movements in HPI and and
therefore affording more equity in the
properties
um so I think what what I expect to see
over the next six months is that we will
see more customers
um with financial stress and but I
expect that to be
um relative to the to the market and and
I think there are options options
available to those customers as well and
so customers that are experiencing
financial difficulties at maturity and
that's when we explore to understand
what kind of forbearance measures may be
appropriate or not for different
individuals so I think I would expect in
this higher interest rate environment
that we see more and more financial
stress than we have done to date and but
I also understand that that will be
spread quite differently across
households and will be felt differently
across households
anyone wants to say any different to
that
Bradley
and then I'll come to Andrew so again
just in terms of the payment increase I
think it's important to recognize what
that means for customers so currently
mortgage rates
of somewhere between in the market say
five and a half to six and a half
um obviously depending on on lender at
six percent the payment increase for
customers coming off a rate of Circa 2.3
percent is 350 pounds per month increase
so so it's it's significantly more so in
in this environment you'd expect
therefore to Charlotte's point that you
would expect customers or more customers
to have some financial difficulty
I was just going to a couple of builds
so with similarly to everyone else we
obviously a stress test customers to
make sure they could afford a much
higher payment
um than that then they would be paying
today
we also allow customers to lock into a
race six months ahead of their product
mature ring
and that gives them options
it's a bit too not only just lock in the
rate today but to start planning for
that higher rate six months ahead so it
does give customers some opportunities
to start planning if they've got a an
increasing rate coming down the line the
other thing that I would say is that
historically mortgage arrays have been
highly correlated with unemployment and
undoubtedly the financial cost of living
crisis and inflation is really
challenging but while unemployment is
still low that obviously provides people
with again with options and and uh
they could find in different ways to
manage their payments it's challenging
but they still have you know
unemployment is still low
thank you well I think that moves us
nicely into the subject uh of the
mortgage Charter rationara hey well good
morning and thank you uh I uh so so I
wondered if you could quickly run
through how much of an impact uh you
expect the mortgage Charter to have
he would like to stop and then from the
left yeah Henry
to be seen I think it's the honest
answer
um so we talked we saw really high
take-up rate of payment holidays during
covid a different uh different option a
different uh period as well and put that
into context we saw over 25 000 people
take a payment holiday in the first few
days uh of the of the auction being
there in March 2020
um 100 000 in two weeks and over 200 000
over the duration of
um the availability of those options
so that kind of gives a bit of a
benchmark
um I think it's hard to fully say what
the takeout rates will be my personal
views would be lower than that
um I think the key change that we're
seeing so actually perhaps put it into
context all the options in the mortgage
Charter are available today
um including an interest-only concession
for example the key change is those
options uh particularly interested only
concessions will be available without
affordability assessment and without an
impact on credit file so
at the moment we see about 100 customers
a month taking that option
but we know the credit file impact is a
barrier to people taking that up
so that gives you kind of like the the
ranger that could be
I think the important component that
customers need to understand is that if
they do take an interesting concession
for six months or they extend term
they will they will ultimately pay more
interest it's costly so that's something
that we we're including within the
application process for those for those
options and so probably the message from
me would be really only take these
options if you need to because there
will be a long-term cost okay
and you
you sorry um if everyone else could if
there are things you want to add to the
point that Henry's made that would be
helpful not Andrew
I was going to say I think it's uh we
welcome the mortgage Charter we think
it's helpful for consumers and customers
to have a clear idea of what banks will
offer them and I think this provides
that
um similarly to Henry we provide a
number of these
options for customers already so I
mentioned the opportunity to
fix six months poor maturity
but it does provide consumers to
customers with a deal of clarity on what
they can do and can expect from the
lenders
point so
so
um I think in terms of level of take-up
and customer seeking those options yes
remains to be seen and to Henry's point
I would also expect that will be lower
than what we saw with payment deferrals
during the pandemic I think touching on
one of your points under around customer
certainty and it is a different
environment that we're in today there
was
um you know very little certainty during
Kobe around what that meant for finances
what it meant for employment and work
and what customers understand now is
what that certainty of payment might
look like over the next 12 24 months and
and the options available so I would
expect it to be lower but we're also
equally preparing for
um you know customer inquiries coming to
us
um Bradley United did you have anything
to add to those books one point to add
would be what we've seen most recently
and is a point that Henry raised is
customers who have a mortgage product
that's expiring
um over the last few months less than
four percent of those customers are
inquiring about a mortgage Charter type
solution obviously pre-mortgage Charter
but but a term extension or a conversion
of their mortgage to help affordability
so again to Henry's point we would
expect the numbers to be lower than than
the pandemic in terms of the payment
holiday situation but again you're more
likely to extend terms the length of the
repayment repayment yeah I mean I think
I think it would depend on as custom
circumstances and what we would
encourage customers to do is is to
contact us as lenders to to talk through
those options and understand all the
options before they decide because if a
customer can afford the increased
payments then longer term is better for
them because they'll pay less interest
of course not do anything to add yeah
the mortgage Charter uh we're a
specialist by to let lend us but the
mortgage Charter does not apply to buy
to let however we are following its it's
the charter itself and we would be very
happy to sign the charter if we were
required to I mean should you be
included should should
I it's it's because the evidence
suggests that it affects the the there's
distress in in that sector as well
yeah so I mean
I don't know why
to let was excluded but um but we're
very happy to sign the charter
could I could I make a company
I mean the options around extending term
or moving to interest only
a high proportion of vital that
customers are already on interest only
so those options don't really apply in
that situation I should also mention
length of extension
sorry the extension does it applied they
can already be a difference to an
interest only uh right to China
um
I I should have mentioned that we
already offer the option for
um customers to extend um out to
retirement we see between 800 and a
thousand of those applications per month
that doesn't have an impact on credit
file no affordability so perhaps a
benchmark of of that sort of take up
going forward
so what is the point of the mortgage
Charter then if you're doing much of
what's written up is it that just people
know a bit more about where they stand
and it's in one place
has the chance to added anything I think
substantial substantive terms by growing
up with this mortgage Charter
oh sorry I think it
provides consumers and customers to be
Clarity around what's out there and
consistency
um so different lenders have had
different approaches yeah um so I think
it does that I also think that
inflation is still high so there's still
the ongoing squeeze for uh customs and
consumers so I think it's Health
intervention that if things as things uh
progress so 85 of the market is covered
by this voluntary Charter according to
one report there's 50 15 who are not do
view on whether the government should
reach out to them and and encourage them
or or kind of try and influence them to
to support sign up to this Charter I
think these are those that are that are
would it would be appropriate for them
to sign up
given you think it's quite a good thing
anyone think each lender will have its
own reasons if if they aren't signing to
the Charter and it may be to Nigel's
point of being about a specialist lender
I don't know just from a Santander
perspective we're supporting the child
and signing up
okay and so what we what we know in
terms of overall figures is that
um we're going to see 1.4 million
households that are set to roll off
fixed rates over the course of this year
and as the chair has said most of them
are two to five year you know two years
uh up to five year years ago
um uh and we're on much lower rate so we
are going to see much more stress in the
system do you do you think what do you
think you could be doing above and
beyond what's there in the mortgage
Charter and what you've been doing to
try and minimize the risk of
repossessions or distress even if they
don't face reposition it's going to
cause a huge amount of financial
distress if your mortgage you know
average mortgage in London is going to
be go up by over five and a half
thousand nationally it's just under
three thousand
have you got a view on what banks what
more Banks can do
Andrew
if I outline the way we we thought about
in what we're doing that might help with
some um some context in the way that
we're thinking about approaching this
so there's three largely three groups of
customers there's those customers that
are coming off
fixed rates
and for those customers we allow them to
selects a product six months before that
maturity again so that allows I said
well that allows them to plan
we've also looked at within there what
customers are at potentially a high risk
and we phoned those customers to to not
only allow them to lock in but also to
an extent term if they need to so that's
on that group of customers rolling off
those fixed term products so we're we've
got us we've got we try to help those
customers and for them those most at
risk we are proactively reaching out to
them
then there's a group of Customs on
variable rate products
so for those customers every single
customer gets at least one communication
a year that tells them what the products
available
if you can make a saving at all we'll
send you another communication and tell
you to make a saving by moving to a
different product so for example if you
could save 100 pounds a month or so you
can save up to 100 pounds a month so
we're really explicit in that
communication and again for for those
customers you think are at most risks of
cost of living we do outbound calling
and we've called 35 000 customers to let
them know that there is the potential
for uh another product to move to
and then finally there are customers in
financial difficulties and we've got a
suite of tailored forbearance activities
for those Customs to try and keep people
in their homes and you know only use
repossessions the last as the last
resort
does anyone else want to add yeah it's
just what an additional point is we use
quite an extensive Suite of early
warning indicators so if you wait until
a customer has has not paid then our
view is always trying to anticipate that
and deal with it early so we use
everything from uh obviously listening
to reaching out to customers in a
similar way as described by Andrew but
but also we use a lot of quite smart
technology to try and identify early
signs of stress in an individual's life
that may not be evident yet in their
payment performance and if we do see
that we reach out to the customer and
try and understand the issue and then
offer help where uh where it's needed
just find out finally um do do any of
you know about mortgage prisoners and
what the implication of the rising
interest rates are going to be for them
do you have people who are attract in in
the mortgage prisoner kind of category
and also how do you you know do you have
a view on the fact that the extension of
mortgages or the the the break if you
like does mean that the cost overall
cost burden will be pushed back to later
on in life and then what are the you
know what are your thoughts on that
because people aren't people are still
going to be worse off it's just about
deferring uh the pain if you like
any any thoughts on either of those
points
pick up the second Point
um
so you know people are standing term now
for example to manage their payments
when they come to renew their product in
the future
um it may be those the rates have
reduced at that point as part of the
um product switch Journey that we have
we encourage people to review their term
again then so at that point when racer
come down potentially they can reduce
down their term and therefore reduce the
total amount of Interest they pay
they'll still be worse off then well
they'd have incurred more interest
during that initial period but
the the early they do that the less any
other comments on on either of those
points just on the mortgage prison up
front from a Santander perspective we
offer rates to all our customers so
there's no customers it's similar to
Andrew in terms of the contact strategy
of customers on variable rates so that
they are aware of other products that
they can fix onto if that's what they
prefer we have 90 of our customers at
the moment in fixed rates and only 10
invariable
and the the affordability changes that
we push for in this committee from
absolute to relative tests for those who
are attracting as mortgage prisoners is
that have you have you used that
as you've done the assessments I know
there's a second piece of work underway
at UK Finance to look at mortgage
prisoners and particularly to try and
understand the data better from those
closed book lenders so we can tailor our
approaches and that work is ongoing
currently with you you do know that I've
been campaigning us for years in this
committee the bank the FCA had revised
the uh guidance uh from an absolute test
to a relative test to perform stability
we were assured that things would then
change and people would be able to have
access to more mortgages and favorable
rates and be able to switch and it seems
very slow the work that's got underway
one of you is on the FCA board
um to get this going and now people are
you know stuck in this situation with
Rising interest rates so it's going to
be even worse for them uh can we have
some urgency please
I just can't we we have no mortgage
prisons on our on our portfolio every
customer can get a front book rate and
we have adjusted our uh affordability
for Mortgage business
um we see very little coming through but
when we looked at it previously we did
see that there were a number of uh
Customs applying to us from closable
lenders but not necessarily categorizing
themselves as as Mortgage business
thanks very much thank you and just in
terms of the mortgage Charter
you're going to be subject to the
consumer Duty from the end of July do
you see any contradictions between what
you're being required to do by the
consumer Duty and what you're being
required to do as signatories of the
mortgage Charter or do you think they're
completely aligned anyone want to answer
that one
I think the key point for
um the charter is around the customer
awareness and understanding and that's
that's the key component to make sure
that when customers are choosing to
um temporary move to interest only or a
term extension that's really clear up
front and that there might be cost
implications what those cost
implications can be and and if the
customer then chooses and is comfortable
with that to proceed and that's so
that's okay and I think that Clarity is
where it's um much needed and and that's
the process that we're currently working
on now to make sure that we've built
that into the into the processes that
customers have a real awareness of what
that means in terms of the longer term
financials
Alloys and Santander you both mentioned
that you're contacting customers
proactively about uh a lot of this
yesterday we heard on our campaign as a
committee to increase savings rates
one of the reasons Banks were not
increasing savings rates is because they
couldn't contact their customers to tell
them that higher savings rates were
available because of restrictions around
gdpr so we think that's a very
implausible excuse and we would just
like you to feed that back to your
employers uh Douglas yeah thanks very
much chair and good morning
um can we just start with a quote that
I've got from citizens about Scotland
that says 11 to 14 of people can't make
it to the end of the month on their pay
due to a combination of the cost of
living energy costs and maybe with
mortgage increases I think Henry in your
opening question you said that you're
not seeing a huge spike in level debt
and I think that was echoed by other
members on the panel
um so I you know I'm just wondering what
all what level of mortgage do you think
you'll begin to see uh
can maybe
underpayment or no payment being made
towards people's mortgages given the
pressure that is is on households I mean
yeah
um it's hard to hard to give a exact uh
rate uh it would be different for each
individual one High Street I've been
talking to said that once rates get
limited to seven percent that's maybe
the cutoff point where we'll see an
exponential rise so the increase I
referenced at the start the 235 pounds a
month is assuming at five and a half
percent pay rate
um and coming from
um a sort of two and a quarter
um percent pay rate currently
um
we talked about the impact of the
mortgage Charter
um extending term would would reduce
that increase to about 134 pounds a
month so it takes about 100 pounds off
that increase if they convert to
interest only
they could move to a lower payment than
they have currently so even though their
rate will increase moving to interest
learning more than offset that increase
and that remains true until you get to
somewhere between six and uh six and a
quarter and six and a half percent so
that that might be a kind of tipping
point at which options like interest
only won't be sufficient to offset the
increase in payments that the customers
will see
Andrew do you have any comment on that
nothing nothing other to build other
than to say I think the fact that
unemployment remains low
means that although
there is definitely a real challenge for
households in terms of spending there
are still choices that the customers can
can make to try and keep stay in their
homes and we'll we support them in that
through
things like Henry's Outlet moved to
interest only and um term extensions
yeah so so some of the options that you
can offer customers are moving to
changing the balance between interest
and capital repayments every month and
address only and uh if there's some form
of
um holiday that they could take in terms
of overall but um maybe Charlotte and
Bradley what would you think you know I
think people are trying to find ways of
paying all these bills and dealing with
inflation and all the other things have
got to deal with at the moment so what
what do you think is the
um
the source of
people's increment in terms of trying to
but not the source of anything but what
are they using to actually pay their
mortgage and find these little bills
that you've seen any Trends in terms of
maybe people using up savings or what
are the percentages of people who are
actually moving to a different term or
changing the the conditions of their
mortgage because it's all very well
saying yeah we're seeing people or the
people have got options to do that but
if they understand the trends and how
many people were actually doing it then
that may be quite useful from like a
committee's perspective as well and so
from and skipton's data to date we
aren't seeing
um
material uplift in in customers choosing
those options or requiring to choose
those options so and our customers that
are
um entering into areas has remained
consistent so we're not seeing an uplift
in that we also know that um within the
data when we're talking to customers
that are experiencing financial
difficulty that that is more driven by
life events rather than the rate
environment so that's still an illness
or unemployment
um
but I suspect that when when we see
higher rates we will start to see more
of an uplift of customers choosing these
options it's but we're not seeing that
today
is it yeah so a similar a similar
picture for us at Santander I think we
are seeing some customers and you see in
I get from bank account customers and
the turnover data and understanding of
the data there you do see some customers
that are looking to cancel subscriptions
and that sort of thing which would be an
early sign we don't see any particular
deterioration in our unsecured customers
who have unsecured debt so it doesn't
seem to be at this moment in time any
lead indicators that they're struggling
to pay there I think from our
perspective we're we're just looking to
support our customers and and the
customers that have similar to to other
members on the panel we've contacted 1.8
million customers this year targeted
Outreach those customers again that we
feel are at risk potential of having
financial difficulty encouraging them to
contact the bank
um to discuss you know any any issues
they have and for us to support them and
again similarly we have a range of
measures in place to support those
customers through that period okay uh
and new customers as well
um you know what what because what level
are you you're stressing there
um interest payments and general
mortgage repayments if there's new
customers to the bank or the building
Society so so similarly in terms of what
we've done previously we still stress
mortgage customers their affordability
at a higher rate than the pay rate so
typically that might be depend dependent
on the customer but it may be two or
three percent above their their pay rate
but but typically in the market you know
lenders will be stressing at this moment
in time somewhere between eight and nine
percent pay rate to ensure that
customers have future affordability I
think could I just
as well and when we look at
affordability we'll look at interest
interest rate risk and stress tests for
that we also will look at an expected
household household expenditure and so
what these customers what's new
customers
um to lenders will also be undergoing a
full affordability assessment which
which assesses both elements and so that
will factor in and current and
inflationary costs and how what it costs
to run a household as well so
um that will be factored into an
affordability assessment
do you seeing any increase in the number
of rejected applications on the basis of
affordability
so we're not seeing that in our data
currently
um in terms of decline rates however
what I would say is that
um 90 of customers that come to
um the society are introduced via a
broker and Brokers will run an
affordability assessment up front so
whether or not they're seeing
um a variation in that data it would be
in the intermediary Market weather theme
where you would or wouldn't accept cases
but once they're placed we're seeing a
similar level of Etc right okay and is
it the same with lines and
nationwidebridge you see it's exactly
that point Brokers will kind of filter
the applications are separate is this
study around 80 uh the other other thing
we will be seeing is perhaps borrowers
particularly first-time buyers may be
saving for a bigger deposit or buying
slightly different property
um so so I think you know there has been
an impact on affordability
um we have
um uh a two-tier approach so our
standard affordable ability is stressed
at just under nine percent it's there's
rules around your revert rate plus one
percent that drive that
where we specifically Target our extra
support for first-time buyers so whether
they take a five-year fix or longer you
can apply a different view of stress
rate so we apply lower stress rate in
that situation to try and support
first-time buyers through through this
period
and you see in Andrews any or first-time
buyers still involved in the market are
they still coming forward to actually
purchase new new Properties or yeah
um we lose bankrupt do around one in
five first-time buyers so it's an
important
um one part of the market for us um one
that we we're really committed to
the market is smaller in 2023 than 2022
because
21 and 22 are very very large years due
to
the race for space post covered where
people you know change their living
living habits and Living Styles
and then you have the stamp Duty holiday
so that drove two very big ears so it's
sort of understandable to the market
this year is going to be smaller than
those two years and it's more aligned to
2019. so yes it's down but it's looks
it's more normalized in its size
um there's still
um but within that first-time buyers
have also reduced as you'd expect
but people as Henry said people are
either putting down a larger deposit or
buying a smaller property because
affordability is tighter we won't let
people as much
now with rates that where they are as he
would have done historically so so yes
people are moderating what they can
afford to buy yeah
and because of that are we seeing any
changes in I mean there may be original
but any changes in those places
I guess we published house price index
so you can see it's a moderation in
house prices but again it's um
small and we I think we in our q1
results we said that the we expected
them to fall around five percent this
year okay let me move on just very
quickly to the bike to light sector
Nigel as well and just to see what
changes you're seeing within that sector
and whether you're experiencing lenders
or whatever actually stress testing
anybody who wants to move into that
sector at the moment although I know
there's a lot of issues around the
sector as a whole at the moment but I
just wanted to hear what we review was
in terms of bike to letting where that
sits at the moment
yeah so stress testing applies equally
in buy to let the model is different
because you have rental income as
opposed to normal
employment income to consider but you
know the industry and we do employ
stress tests in order to assess whether
the affordability is uh is achievable
not just today but at higher interest
rates as well they will vary depending
upon the customer and the customer type
whether they are a single property
landlord or a multiple property landlord
equally also depends on the tax rates as
well so it's a little more complicated I
think than than the unoccupied Market
however what we have seen more generally
is there is certainly a weaker level of
demand out there which is probably not
surprising given General Trends in the
economy the housing market and the like
there's also perhaps a tendency for for
individuals to stick with their existing
lender a little longer
so they they stay on the books and take
a product transfer so take another fixed
rate but within
the within the firm as well
and what we what we also have seen is uh
the kind of the changing Dynamics Within
The Wider The Wider uh buy to let Market
or The Wider private rented sector where
demand for rented property remains very
strong it's it's very strong and you
know I'm sure at some point you'll want
to talk about
um what's happening in the rental market
but what you see is that the
affordability tests that we establish
are we typically you want something like
a minimum of around 150 percent rent to
debt service coverage ratio
so you've got a buffer to allow for
increases in interest rates and
increases in costs to manage those
properties typically we we're running at
around 200 percent now so you've got
capacity to absorb those higher interest
rates and costs in managing the
properties as well
is there any concern as an insector just
know if if you I think you said earlier
that a lot of the battle lights are on
an interest only basis so in terms of
maybe falling house prices and the
capital they might have invested into a
property is that a concern within the
sector as well yeah so I I think there
is a there is a certain perception
around bitalat that it is a a riskier
product
um I would dispute that actually I've
probably built a career out trying to
dispute it I've not necessarily
succeeded
um but if you look the average loan to
value is 62 and a half percent on our
portfolio
uh it's very different to what life was
like before the financial crisis but you
know our loan to values are not
untypical of the industry uh as a whole
and one of the reasons why
lenders don't typically do much more
than 75 loan to value
is because actually you want to ensure
that the investor the landlord has got
an investment in the property it's not
the roof over his head
but we will you you want to make sure
that he is invested in the property so
typically the maximum loan to values you
will do will be lower and that is very
much again it's not just a paragon thing
it's across the industry as a whole
good night just to Echo just to Echo
that from a
um a Skipton group perspective where
we've got um connell's group estate
agency in letting on and we see the same
Trends so
um I think nine seventy percent of The
Bachelorette properties are mortgaged 30
aren't and are none of those that are
mortgage 90 of them are less than 70
loan to value so there is a significant
amount of equity in the property
I'd also point out on the arrear
statistics
again the perception of buy to let being
a riskier product
um if you look at the buy to let arrays
for the industry they stand today at
0.43 that compares to the owner-occupied
market at 0.78 so it's almost half the
level
and you might think is this just a
one-year wonder if you go back to every
year since
data was recorded it has been the same
vitalet has been a lower level of
arrears than owner occupied
with one exception and that was 2009
which clearly we all remember what
happened but that was largely created by
Bradford and Bingley there were stood at
six percent
you take them out and you get back to
the same trend line
so hence one of the points of why I
think people misunderstand the credit
stand in of the landlords in the buy to
let Market the evidence actually points
to it being much stronger than the
perception
thank you very much and we will be
asking more questions on on
Nigel that you would want to acknowledge
that landlords can also be women and say
he or she when you're referring to
landlords Emery thank you Jeff
now turn to the availability of
mortgages uh Douglas has looked at the
affordability but we've seen very
volatile positions where rates have been
offered then they've been withdrawn and
there is a concern I think among many
who want a mortgage as to at what point
do they do they lock in and for money
there was a question mark about whether
they want fixed or whether they want
some form of variable tracker related
product so when you look at the
availability of mortgages now
um what are you seeing and what are you
intending to offer in your portfolio to
reflect that changing demand of what
individuals want and your challenge with
in inflation and interest rates changing
very very quickly and perhaps I can
start with Bradley
sure so um thank you I think what we're
seeing from a new availability for
customers and we've already touched upon
it so far is from an affordability
perspective clearly if you were a
customer and what we see typically for
first-time buyers or people moving house
is the first question they'll ask a
broker because 85 of the market of
origination of new of new mortgages come
come via intermediaries the first
question their last Brokers is how much
can I borrow what's my maximum I can
borrow so they know when they go and
view properties what their budget is how
much Equity they've got on there for
they have a price in mind what we're
clearly seeing now from in terms of the
way we stress affordability and and
Charlotte's Point around the fact that
the customers General bills are higher
food and fuel Etc means that customers
for their maximum borrowing is less than
what it was a year ago or 18 months ago
so clearly that's going to constrain
customers choices and and and what
properties they can afford and again to
Andrew's point we can see some signs
where customers are either putting more
deposit down or or looking for a all the
property from terms of availability of
products I think we are seeing it's been
a very volatile period
um base rate's been increasing
um swap rates have been increasing which
is which is generally the funding cost
for banks and therefore there have been
price increases by lenders
um we are we are super conscious of that
and and actually what we do is give
Brokers notice in advance that our
products will be changing so if products
are being withdrawn and new products
launched at higher rates it gives
Brokers the opportunity to book those uh
those rates for the customers before
they're withdrawn before they're changed
so that customers have at least some
option or right okay I know this is the
price today maybe that's changing
tomorrow we've given notice and
therefore the the broker can book that
and similarly to Andrew's point for
existing customers we allow customers to
pre-book their rates we write to them
before before their deals mature and
allow them to pre-book and as part of
the charter although available before
customers then we've committed to if
those rates go down and they have
pre-booked a rate because their new
rates are ending in three or four months
that actually they can change that rate
and take the lower rate before there
before then you do start the way you're
talking leads me to conclude that you
are still very much focused on a fixed
rate uh type of mortgage Arrangement
rather than anything which is more
flexible unmask you Andrew
share that view or do you think there is
now a demand for and maybe an appetite
on the part of the banks to look at that
sort of product or do you see that as
high risk and something you're going to
try and persuade borrowers not to look
at we offer two EFX 5dfx tan and we have
a Tracker product so trackers were
completely out of favor in the market
for a number of years
um people and everyone went for a two or
five year fixed
post uh the money budget when there was
volatility in the market trackers became
very popular and we didn't have a
Tracker in the Market at that particular
time so we introduced it in January
to recognize the customer demand for
that product I think it's a helpful
product for volatility
and I think it worked for some customers
in October November because it was
volatile and rates actually did come
down it allowed people to have the
flexibility that a Tracker offers
um
so we we offer
we think we're offering a full Suite of
products that customers at this point in
time would find any school on want
um and the advice process that customers
go through is critical in determining
which product is suitable and
appropriate for them
Charlotte can I ask you this
um
you uh earlier quite rightly referred to
the number of owners that don't have
mortgages
do you see as the cost of living crisis
begins to bite an increasing number of
older people wanting to take out new
mortgages and do you see the sector
beginning to address the issue because
you've not only got individuals who
maybe want to be borrowers not for the
first time but again as they get older
but also those who are already with
mortgages who are still working well
into their 70s and 80s who are still
more than capable because they are still
waged if I can put it like that to
repair their their mortgages is that
something which is being addressed in
the structure of the war which is which
you're offering
and so
to your second Point around lending into
what would be retirement age if people
are working and able to evidence through
um regular income we we will lend in
that space
um with no age barrier if you're in if
you're in work it doesn't hold you are
you can still take a product well so we
assess individual
um individual circumstances on that in
terms of what how far into what would be
retirement and and if they can if
there's evidence of income and that's
sustainable then yes we would look at
that for customers
um the the first point around customers
that are currently mortgage free and
looking to release Equity from their
property and the market exists today
it's not something that in terms of
equity release
um it's not something that skipped and
lends on I think
um I think do we will we see that as a
growing Market potentially and it may
not actually be to service their own
households but whether or not we see
more in terms of intergenerational and
lending as well for people supporting
um Sons or daughters or and family as
well so that may be a growing Market
so Bradley asks us what you do offer
Equity release so do you see this as a
growing way of people
um being able to to manage their
finances going forwards and that is the
the original structure which I think
many Saw is quite destructive because of
the amount of equity that effectively
went to the lender
but the market seems to be changing so
we don't currently offer Equity release
Via Santa no brand we have an
arrangement with a third party where we
refer customers over if that's a type of
lending we lend to age 75 similar
similar to the Skipton providing
customers can evidence income up to that
agent it's affordable for them but if a
customer wants lending past retirement
then an equity release type or later
life lending then we have an arrangement
with a third party that we would refer
them to so they can explore those
options thank you Henry first time
buyers
um we've talked a little bit about
first-time bars and the availability of
mortgages including they're buying
smaller properties and the the
relativity between the equity and the
loan that is clearly changing but what
sort of advice are you giving and what
sort of things are you offering to the
first time buyer because for them
they've got many years ahead of them but
it is an absolutely crucial decision to
make at this point are you looking at
evolving a different range of products
and what availability specifically are
you looking at putting in place for the
first time buyer
um so so uh in terms of our product
offering that hasn't really changed
we've talked about obviously higher
rates but the the range of products
available is unchanged uh I mentioned
earlier our support for first-time
buyers so we have a specific proposition
called Helping Hand which stands up to
95 and up to five and a half times
income
um as I said you know trying to help
first-time buyers uh through this period
and ensuring that they they can
get onto the property ladder
um in terms of advice around whether now
is a good time to buy or or not that's
not something that we would provide
advice on that's very much an individual
decision depends on their circumstances
um so so yeah it's very much as as we
were in terms of offering
um and and as I think Andrew said we're
still seeing uh demand from first-time
buyers
it is a very different market and here
I'm not looking at affordability but
availability there is a lot which has
changed in that sector over the last
decade in terms of tax treatment we now
have the renters Reform Bill on Horizon
all sorts of things impacting that
market
in terms then of the availability of
vitalet mortgages do you foresee any
changes is it something that the sector
is saying because of all the complexity
uh that's coming down the line This is a
product which we don't want to continue
offering in the same volume as we did
before
I don't see a reduced appetite from the
industry
um the I'd say the competition as it
were is as intense as ever in that space
and I think there is plenty of capital
available from the industry to support
that market now and going forward I
think if anything there might be a
shortage of landlords
we probably see that most evidently
through the shortage of the stock of
properties available to rent which has
other consequences which we can no doubt
talk about talk about later but I don't
think there's any shortage of supply of
funding or capital from the industry as
a whole whether it be specialist lenders
is it more complicated yes it is more
complicated uh we we choose to focus on
being a specialist lender because we
think we deal with typically more much
more of our businesses towards
professional landlords one of the things
they have to wrestle with and deal with
is 169 different forms of Regulation and
legislation and they have to be they
have to understand that you know and
they have to apply it
um so we need to make sure we're experts
at that as well in order to deliver the
products and services to the customers
at the same time but it is more
complicated for sure
one final question I'm going to ask you
Andrew
um to what extent do you think your
sector is breaking into its thinking uh
the impact will likely impact of the
current economic position on house
prices the prediction is that they are
going to fall clearly that impacts your
calculation in terms of the products you
offer
to to
lend and how are banks and building
societies taking that into account in
the way they structure their offerings
this probably by its most is for
first-time buyers that will be typically
are at High ltvs
um I think can we touched on this where
it's completely individual situation but
we still think owning a home
for most people is better than renting
and therefore we want to keep products
available at RL TVs for first-time
buyers
but we need to make sure that those
first-time buyers are resilient I.E they
can afford to stay in their home through
a two-year period whereas prices might
be falling for example and they're aware
that
they could end up in negative equity so
customers being completely aware of the
of the risk of house price Falls and
find yourself in equity and finding
themselves
vulnerable to unemployment for example
so we're thinking deeply about who do we
lend to and the disclosures
that we make sure customers have about
the potential for any house price Falls
that's where we're that's how we're
thinking about that at the moment
very much
thank you good morning
um you're all sounding incredibly
reasonable and fair and you all have
excellent systems to support your
customers but I'd just like to put out
there that I have a constituent who was
ill and therefore couldn't as a
self-employed person achieve his income
and was assured by his bank that as well
as giving him a payment holiday it
wouldn't impact on his credit file and
so he accepted their offer and it did
impact on his credit file and then he
couldn't remortgage so that left him in
a very dark position so hearing all that
you're saying there's a slight pinch of
salt there because there's a
parliamentary representative trying to
get the bank who I won't name here to
actually be fair to that constituent has
not been possible so far so I think it's
always worth um remembering that whilst
you say you have the systems and you're
reaching out to people if they are
potentially getting into difficulties
that your systems don't always do as you
wish them to and so I I do
want you all to take that on board and
and gives that consideration and
particularly when people do come to you
with with their particular cases and
this I believe is being streamed live on
the BBC and so there will be lots of
people sat out there throwing things at
the television saying this isn't my
experience of of borrowing money so you
know complacency is just not an option
in the current situation
um I did want however to question you
about um house prices property prices
and to understand
um certainly
um Mr Jordan I Believe one of your
colleagues um Chris Rhodes told us last
November that Nationwide Central
scenario would result in house price
Falls of eight to ten percent but
potentially up to 30 percent so could we
um please hear from each of you about
what is your central forecast for house
prices and are you already experiencing
negative equity and and what how will
you deal with
um homeowners who go into negative of
equity I'm starting with you please
thank you so I think uh similar to
Andrew's uh Point earlier we've already
seen some Fallen house prices roughly
about four percent from their peak in
August last year we'd expect uh some
further
um slight Falls to around about six and
a half percent would be our our expected
uh Peak Peak movement
um your question about negative equity
um
we have a very very low exposure to
negative equity currently I think it's
0.1 percent of our of our book
um so we're not seeing uh those those
movements in house prices really have
any any specific bearings sorry but if
if in if uh house prices drop six and a
half percent what will that do to your
negative equity it won't increase
materially so I think it's about two and
a half percent of our book above 90 LTV
right so there's Headroom uh because of
the the house price growth we saw
through through the pandemic and uh
lending standards around High rail TV
learning as well from a customer
perspective
um again as Andrew mentioned if if they
go into negative equity and maintain
their pet their payments you know that
that might be for a fairly short period
and it wouldn't have any direct impact
on them
clearly if they're having wider payment
problems at the same time that's where
the other sport measures that we've
talked about would also kick in
thank you and uh Mr Assam are you seeing
any particular regions where there are
um more impact of negative equity
um or impact on house prices the
the region that's been most impacted is
London the southeast at the moment
according to our index and that's been a
a pattern crediful so we saw the biggest
increase in house prices where there was
most affordability
and now we're seeing London for
potentially because that's where
affordability is obviously most most
stretched
sorry can you can you expand on that a
bit so does that mean that London and
the southeast will suffer more as a
result of drop bigger Falls in house
prices or are you saying that there's
more Headroom in the in the um
affordability for consumers we saw
larger Falls in London
than than the rest of the UK and does
that therefore mean that you are likely
to see more families in negative equity
and potentially more financial
difficulty uh not really if you look at
the ltvs on our portfolio is around 40
High 40s so it's very low
and the average LT loads of value in the
portfolio again means that
we don't expect to see large amounts of
negatively so essentially what you're
seeing then is property prices went up
faster and now have come back down again
so it's sort of less less gain on the
value of your property as opposed to a
negative equity situation right thank
you and um Miss Harrison what about
skipton's situation uh similar view so
in terms of
um again from the estate agency arm
um instructions new instructions to the
market we're seeing about two percent
um reduction from uh to June last year
so on a year year-on-year basis
um equally the average loan to value of
our mortgage book is around 53 so a lot
of customers have significant levels of
equity in their products and sorry in
there and in their mortgage
um and equally for those customers that
um come to rates which and perhaps are
in negative equity which when seeing but
if that's if that materializes we have
products available for them as well
right and the same for you Mr Porter and
Mrs tarrington similar situation very
similar our average loan to value is 51
for customers we have less than one
percent of our customers that have a
loan to value above 90 so again any in
terms of impact of house price
reductions would have a limited impact
on on negative equity that seems very
low 51 that sort of suggests that you've
not sold many properties recently at
high multiples of income or what what is
or is that because house prices have
rocketed why is that solo the two things
from a new business so that's our
existing customers who may have been
with us for some time from a new
business perspective it's closer to 70
LTV is is the new business average loan
to value there's two aspects of it one
is is obviously house price increases
but also most customers 90 or so take a
repayment mortgage and therefore over
time they're paying their Capital down
which they therefore increases their
Equity as well so you kind of get a dual
effect but on the one hand you're saying
you're lending people large amounts
against a property but the loan to value
is very low so that doesn't quite stack
up with new customers does it
so those customers have a range of LTV
points our average for new customers is
67 LTV there will be some customers that
clearly we lend 90 or 95 to but on
average and obviously some customers who
have a very low LTV who have more Equity
possibly moving home rather than a
first-time buyer and is that their
choice or are you forcing that upon them
no so again similarly we have a range of
products up to 95 for our customers you
know we we rely on our advisors and also
intermediaries to give customers advice
to understand what's the best product
for them
um be that availability of trying to put
down a little bit more deposit we see
more gifted deposits now than
historically for you know customers who
are getting help from family family
generally parents or grandparents that
help with deposits which then can make
the mortgage therefore affordable if
they put more deposit down so I mean
arguably the the difference between now
and the um 2009 scenario is that people
are perhaps more risk-averse less
willing to take on a huge
loan to value ratio themselves would you
say that that's the case or would you
say that the lenders themselves have
become much more conscious of
affordability it definitely lenders are
more conscious there is regulation that
supported that so we talked about the
affordability stressing yeah above the
pay rate and also that from A lender
from there's a a pra rule where you can
only lend 15 of your lending new lending
to customers above an income multiple of
four and a half times so so there is
some some regulation in play to make
sure that it's responsible lending and
would you say that that therefore
um leads to the conclusion that that's
what makes it so difficult for young
people to get onto the housing ladder no
I think it's a number of factors that
that house prices
um currently affordability is more is
more difficult than what we've seen in
the past which we've touched upon but I
think it's ensuring that we're
responsible lenders are making sure
customers can afford mortgages both now
and in the future and I think that's the
most important point and how are housing
transactions hold up generally
question to all of you are we seeing a
decline or an increase in house
transactions as as the value of them
goes down a bit
and housing transactions all are down uh
they're probably off around about 20 to
25 percent
from where they were
um sort of the back end of last year I
think the is that seasonal law is that
well I think it's probably been affected
by the rising interest rates
there was a disruption around what
happened to the mini budget
but you also have you've had a couple of
years worth of high levels of distortion
in the housing market so if you go back
to probably a time before disruption
like 2019 then you're still looking at
housing activity lower today than it was
in 2019. you had a big surge at various
points during covid but but but it's
still lower and it's likely to remain
lower this year I think right
changing consumer behavior in it for new
purchases are people looking for longer
term fixes are they tending to stay on
variable rate mortgages in the hope that
interest rates will come down and
perhaps Mr Assam
in customers take longer mortgages so
the proportion of customers taking
mortgages over over 25 years has
increased
um that's a web managing so that's
repayment terms and what about the fixed
rate aspect of that are they fixing for
longer yeah sorry that's that's what
that's what I meant
um no they're not fixing for longer so
the split between two and five year
fixed has moved more to two years
they're fixing for a shorter period in
the hope that interest rates will come
down yeah right okay and are are any of
you offering longer term fixing seven
ten years we offer a 10-year fix and
we've offered that consistently
and our 10 year fixes at a lower rate
than our two and five year fix and are
you all in the same situation are you
all offering seven and ten year fixed
rates not seven but ten sorry
seven but ten yeah yes and we we
typically see very low takeout rates of
that
sort of less than two percent two to
five percent on on some periods but
despite the fact that Andrew outlined
its uh our lowest price product
um we see very low takeovers but you're
not offering it yeah so you would see
you after 10 year but not seven ah okay
and are you all offering 10-year fixed
rates we're not currently
um offering 10-year fixed rates we have
in the past and and again very very
little take up
okay thank you very much
um and then um are you finding that
customers are shopping around for the
best deal more often than they used to
is is there much more mobility of people
choosing to refinance with a better
cheaper provider
um Miss Harrison I think I think I think
I think seen
my mind and similar levels in terms of
again I go about 90 of our business
that's introduced to us comes via a
broker so they will be always actively
searching for the best deal and for
their customers I think what we are
seeing is more um switching of products
and between point of
um application to the point of
completion so that is a trend that we're
starting to see more of that as we had
interest rate movements within fixed
rates that people are choosing to switch
to a different alternative closer to the
standard completion if it's cheaper for
them so okay a small Trend that we're
seeing and how easy is it to refinance
with another provider once you've
already got a mortgage with one provider
is it still incredibly costly and
difficult to do that
Mr Sam uh no I think it's easy the
market is highly intermediated so lots
of Brokers as everyone said 85 of new
mortgages go through a broker the broker
will find the right deal for the
customer in their lives this is
remortgaging this is consumers saying I
don't like this mortgage provider it
doesn't make a deal over there how
costly and complex is it to do that most
of those deals have free legal services
and free valuations associated with them
so it should be easy to do so a message
to Consumers tuned in today would be
shop around you could even switch
mortgage provider and get a better deal
yeah talk to your mortgage broker thank
you very much please don't worry about
the Bell we will all stay here Angela
yeah thank you uh very much chair um
mortgage costs of today uh risen to the
highest level for 15 years with the
average rate on a two-year fixed
mortgage now passing the peak of what
happened in the aftermath of the mini
budget the bank of England say that the
rate on new mortgages in this country is
much higher than it is in other
countries 4.5 to 6 percent although I
suspect it will be higher now in the UK
compared to three percent in France and
3.95 in Germany why
Mr Assam why
the way that we price the mortgage
product has a number of different
components in it so for example costs
operational
capital
and then the big drive over recent
months has been the external funding
cost of the two-year swap or five years
are you talking about the price of gelts
that's having a direct effect on why our
mortgages are so much more expensive
than mortgages you could get in other
European countries is that
a fair point to make
that that is the link yeah that's where
the pricing comes from
does everybody agree with that
everyone's nodding okay I want to talk
about the buy to let
sector who who's giving evidence there
are known Mr Turlington you specialize
in the um buy to Let's exercise I'm
going to be asking you some specific
questions but does everybody else have a
buy to let section
will offer it you all do okay great
um what I'm trying to get a handle on
now is the pass-through from mortgage
interest increases into rental increases
for people who happen to be in the
rental market how quickly do you think
rate Rises on buy to let mortgages feed
through to rents
Mr turrington yeah I don't I don't think
that there is
um an immediate and direct effect as
much as people might might think so if
you look there's about 5.5 million
properties in the private rented sector
and if you look there are two million
um according to UK Finance 2 million
mortgages on that sector that only
represents 37 so clearly there are 63
percent of people who do not have a
mortgage
um so they are not experiencing an
increasing income in their funding costs
separately
the vast majority of lending into the
buy to let Market is similar to that
you've heard elsewhere is on a fixed
rate basis about 90 of our lending is on
a fixed rate basis and it's interest
only mainly it is interesting it makes
it more sensitive to and price wise to
risers in interest yes but what we do to
compensate that is we have some very
strict affordability tests and we
typically lend at low ltvs so that's for
the person that's
buying the property property Union
rental income to do so with a mortgage
um but if they're
um if their costs rise
they could very quickly pass those on
the ones that have mortgages to renters
at the end of the six-month period
the contract
um lasts for example there's been a five
percent increase in rent in May which is
the highest increase in seven years and
well ahead of earnings growth so there
is quite
quite a big pass-through
so the there is typically a very clear
long-term correlation but between wage
increases and Rental inflation and you
can track this back decades
to look at it obviously there are leads
and lags between that things don't
always happen in the same same year but
that's what typically happens so I think
we there was Labor Market data out out
this morning I think where wage
inflation is running at around 7.6 in
the private sector a little bit lower in
the public sector and the rental
increases there is the ons data of five
percent
um it's kind of therefore not really out
of line with that General Trend in wage
inflation rent have gone up 20 in three
years wages haven't gone up 20 in three
years I said there are there are leads
leads and lags to this if you look at
the experience during covid there was
experience of rent well but rents
declined during that period well there
was there was regulation on rental
increases during covid so let's look at
the period before
um that unusual period to look at what's
happening and what we're seeing is a
Relentless increase in rent which is
exacerbating the cost of living
pressures for
um people who were who can't get on the
housing ladder and because the barriers
to entry are too high for them they seem
to be suffering higher levels of
volatility and increases particularly in
areas where
um property prices have gone up such as
London yeah well as I said there is a
very clear correlation between wage
increases
rents I think if it is being disturbed
at the moment that relationship one of
the factors behind it is that there is a
significant shortage of rental property
um that kind of everywhere you go
everywhere you look you see uh almost
like long queues of tenants looking for
a rental property and the number of
landlords that are in the private rented
sector today is probably lower than
there has been in probably anytime since
2015 and one of the reasons for that is
that you've seen a period here where the
costs have become in a landlord have
gone up and I don't just mean funding
costs but the kind of the overhead of
running a property
in addition to that there's been fairly
significant tax changes that were
introduced around the budget of 2015
that bit on the landlords over a number
of years so many are now being taxed
largely on the revenue they receive
rather than the profit and in addition
to that there's a three percent stamp
Duty surcharge which is a disincentive
to buy so the landlord's costs have gone
up and it has become a less attractive
investment as a consequence so there is
a shortage of property uh in the private
rental sector shows this they've done an
analysis of the rental market which
shows that rental demand if you compare
it to a five-year average is up 51 the
stock of homes available for rent is
down 33 the flow of new Supply is down
nine percent and Rental growth in other
words the cost of renting is up 11 which
is running very very well ahead of wage
increases especially for those who are
either young workers
um who who are who have moved away from
home but can't afford to get on the
housing ladder and or those who are low
paid to what extent is housing benefit
um subsidizing some of this increase has
anyone done any analysis
now how many renters are relying on
housing benefit
respond to that uh the housing benefit
is certainly uh there are there's a
component of the private rented sector
which is is basically a form of social
housing
um if you look at the distribution of
the types of tenants you know there is
probably around 20 percent of the whole
of the private rented sector that is is
in that category
um what you have tended to find those
that because has become less significant
in recent years because there's been a
freeze on the local Authority housing
allowance uh that's available so it has
become a less significant component as a
consequence and if there's one thing
that I think it would be useful for
perhaps the government to look at would
be to unfreeze that because the just
more public subsidy of private renters
buying extra properties isn't it I I
appreciate I understand that point but
what the the issue is is that those
tenants have to compete with the private
sector tenants and if there's no real
Council house alternative then that is
their only source
um
with with without kind of changing the
whole structure of the private rented
sector
there is a direct impact because those
those social focused tenants uh find it
a struggle to compete with the private
sector of course finally
um average entrepreneur lets rather than
average around
clearly with volatility and and price
Rises going up new rentals are going to
cost more with the lack of Supply that
those figures that I've just read out
imply so average rent for new rent have
increased by 11.1 percent in the last 12
months but earnings have increased by
6.7 and lower in the in the public
sector so that is putting an enormous
squeeze as it naught on those in the
rental sector
yes yeah no I I agree with you
um it's it's running ahead of inflation
it's running ahead of wage growth but I
think as I said earlier there is Cycles
to this there are leaves and lags what
we've seen over the last expecting it to
even now well actually I think it's not
a leader that's just been rather a long
leg Yeah there's a if you look at the
rental inflation in the last few months
it hasn't shown much in the way of a
step up
so one suspects we might be moving into
a point where
you start to hit affordability
constraints of tenants and in which case
it doesn't matter what you want to think
you do as a landlord there will be no
real capacity to increase rents but you
might then just sell up
doctor to have anywhere to live I agree
and so the fundamental thing is we need
more Supply into the sector
or more social housing thank you very
much Angela
trips
I want to dig a little deeper into the
structure of the mortgage Market please
and
they manager mentioned that the high
costs of mortgages in the UK compared to
some European countries in particular
but as we've also discussed as a real
difference in the length of mortgages
that people have and I it's a helpful
graph here showing how what's been
outlier the UK is only Ireland seems to
be comparable in the proportion of
mortgages that are very short-term uh
fixed rate
so short term I mean we have
only 10 of mortgages are more than five
years in this country whereas in other
countries I mean Poland seems to have
100 variable
uh Finland whatever 90 uh variable all
these more than 10 years
it's a pattern across the across the
continent
can you just you mentioned how a little
take up uh is this a question for
anybody I'm interested in uh in general
thoughts uh so just jump in but it has
been observed how little take-up there
is how little demand there seems to be
for longer term mortgages can anybody
explain to us why we
syndrome in the UK whereas in in Europe
it seems to be a a different uh a
different trend
who wants to explain
Andrew we've we've we've we've been
asked the question a number of times
around long-term fixed mortgages and why
there's no appetite we survey customers
regularly to see whether there would be
more appetite and every time we ask the
question customers come back and tell us
about the desire for flexibility and the
preference for the shorter term products
and I think it potentially due to the
fact that that would have been the right
thing to do over the last 10 15 years
taking the shorter term product as
interest rates Trend it down now whether
that changes
um as we move through this cycle we need
to wait and see but the market for
10-year fixes before we even think about
15 or 20 or 25 year fixes that we think
is around one or two percent low single
digits
um and it reflect and that's reflecting
in the feedback we get from customers
every time we survey that on
what their preferences are for mortgage
products
any other thoughts I mean interest rates
should be low around the world in the
last 10 years so does that account for
it sufficiently
products of the way in which mortgages
are funded in the UK so I did a lot of
work on this many years ago looking at
what could be done
and the part of the issues the probably
the easiest comparison is the United
States where the market is dominated by
long-term fixed rates and what what
happens is when you have a mortgage
there is what's called you have a clog
on the equity as it as it's called sorry
it's a bit of a legalistic phrase but
but it basically means that you have a
right as a as the homeowner you have a
right to redeem your mortgage at any
time
yes there might be like some
compensation there but it's but what
happens in the United States is let's
say you have a 25-year fixed rate
mortgage at three percent
and rates then go up
no one redeems their mortgage
they stay where they they stay with her
they might Port it to another house but
their mortgage stays where they are if
the inverse was to happen rates come
down from a high level everyone redeems
so what you then have is who who carries
that risk because as Banks and building
societies we want to hedge ourselves to
protect that interest rate risk
so what happens in the United States is
basically there is a price added
so it's it's known as the option
adjusted spread it's a it's a couple of
percentage points added to the interest
rate now if you're offered the
opportunity to have a three-year fixed
rate for five years
or a 25-year fixed rate
for five percent two percent higher
customer demand is such that very very
little take up for the higher interest
rate
so it has been tried by a few banks in
the past with significant failure uh to
attract any interest on it but it has
like like like Andrew has said it has
been looked at on a number of times in
the past and I think the structure of
the way mortgages are funded in the UK
is the dominant feature that's the same
but that's so that's the consequence of
Regulation the U.S has this essential
protection
against these these early repayments do
you think that's something that we
should be considering here do you think
well the you the U.S back some I think
80 years ago created Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac which which facilitated the
ability to create this essentially a
government guarantee that sits behind
the mortgage and then the mortgage is
then packaged in Securities and then
traded so it's traded and looked at
equivalent to a to the U.S treasury or
the UK guilt so if you want to create
that then
that's another Factor but it's taken
them 80 years to get to where they've
got to today okay so just going back to
the point that which is a
comprehensible one which is that
consumers have concluded that rates are
low and trending downwards over the last
10 years so why fix yourself
too long
you know what goes down must come up we
all
recognize that and we're seeing it now
but consumers have been presumably uh
persuaded that rates are going to be low
very indefinitely
I appreciate that you don't advise
the households yourselves but Brokers do
so can anybody tell me what they think
of the role of the brokers in advising
for it was to stick to the short term
fixed rates do you think they have a
role in this do you think they've been
doing their job right over the last 10
years
probably yeah I think Brokers fulfill
really important role in the market and
I think what we see at the moment for
customers is what's most important to
them and it would depend on their
situation so as an example if you're a
first-time buyer or you're moving
property actually it may be what's the
most important thing is how much you can
borrow rather than the actual the actual
rate that you pay within reason of
course and for a customer who's
refinancing coming to the end of their
mortgage product and wanting a new
product it's predominantly going to be
about price
I think to Andrew's Point what we've
seen is historically when we have when
there's been 10-year fixes as an example
in the market they've been more
expensive than shorter term fixes and so
therefore customer advice has been
centered around well what's the cheapest
for me now I want certainty for a period
in time but I also want some flexibility
and and I want the best deal in the
market so that's primarily driven it
whether or not you know in the future
long-term fixes if long-term fixes were
cheaper then you know that that might
drive a different a different demand but
certainly customer demand currently is
is for short-term and flexibility I
reckon I was thinking about the Brokers
I mean presumably they're incentivized
by their uh their own funding model to
prioritize
turnover rates of you know changes
people remortgaging do you not think
that there's a there's a structural
incentive for them to encourage people
to take short terms and then remortgage
and they'd do better that way
um so so in terms of a procuration fee
that lenders pay to Brokers it's it's
the same amount irrespective of the the
length of the product so so there's no
incentive from uh they get paid more I
think there's some definite from an
advice guidelines perspective there are
clear guidelines for those customers
applied by the regulator to ensure that
it's a good customer outcome for that
customer and it fits their circumstances
for this moment in time so if that
customer needs flexibility or wants
flexibility as well as some certainty of
payment then then the broker will give
that appropriate advice okay
the last question if I made to Miss
Harrison I think you said that you were
off from 10 years but not at the moment
is that right is there any other reason
you don't see the demand for it is there
any reason in your business that you
shouldn't be offering a longer term
deals than you are
currently it's purely you just customers
are not asking for it it's demand lead
um we just we don't see the take-up and
equally and
think with Peaks and trucks in terms of
rate cycles and what that could look
like
um you know customers as Bradley just
said that are actively are choosing
against that they want the cheapest deal
available to them so it is demand driven
okay okay so it's not
your own in rates future rates that mean
that you're keeping
sure because because with our fixed rate
um pricing we we hedge against the
interest rate risk and so and that's
hence the the cost in terms of fixed
rate mortgages
[Music]
anyone have any other questions Angela
um yes thank you chair I just wanted to
come back to Mr tarrington
um you were saying that a majority of
people who rent who own rental
properties don't have a mortgage on
those properties but of course they
probably put the rents up
um at the same rate as those who do have
a mortgage on the property since there's
a market there so they're making a lot
of money without having extra costs
aren't they
uh so they're all subjected to the same
more general cost increases so whether
they have a mortgage or they don't but
again I come back to that point it's
there is a significant shortage of of
supply of properties into the sector and
in many places it's acute you know the
student Market is is a particular area
that you know we should be concerned
about because there's clearly a regular
supply of students coming through year
in year out and there is a bit of bed
shortfall as it's measured or something
in the order of a couple hundred
thousand and you know it just becomes so
acute that you know we have heard talk
of some universities can reducing the
intake in order to cope with the
accommodation problems though I I do
genuinely think that there is a supply
issue into the private rented sector uh
driven by a number of assets which I
highlighted highlighted earlier but it's
a bit like any other industry
um you know the reading now about the
cost of Aviation you know the cost of
going on holiday is going up
dramatically because there's a shortage
of flights and uh and staff to be able
to deal with it the hotel industry
having the same the same problems the
restaurant industry closing on certain
days because they don't have the you
know the availability of the supply
chain has been disrupted in a number of
markets and still exists and it's
happening in the private renter sector
final question for me just what your
economists telling you about the
longevity of higher interest rates and
whether
you know this is going to have a long
lasting impact on the UK economy because
it seems to me that you know where we
are looking out to maybe 24 months or
something like that and hoping that all
will go well but you know there's no
guarantee that that could be the case we
could be in this cycle for a good number
of years so
are there any projections that you guys
are picking up that would be
that we as a committee should be
concerned about in terms of her linkages
with the treasury
Henry
um so I think um the market implied view
would be the base rate gets to about six
and a half percent and then uh reduces
down to
four just just maybe just under four
percent over the next couple of years
um so that would feel like it doesn't
lead to a you know a long-term impact of
high high interest rates
um I'd say there's a lot of uncertainty
though around exactly what path interest
rates will follow going forward
any outliners on that well so you're
just you're following the the party line
as regards the outlook for the economy
if that's
yeah that's that's that's what and our
projections look like as well that rates
base rate will rise towards in up to the
end of the year and then over the longer
term
um potential will fall back moderate
moderately and we're not expecting that
it will go back to what we've seen in
2021 2022 in the immediate future
yes just one one additional point is
that you know the market is expecting
interest rates to rise further from here
stay up at that level and then come down
if you look
at the Swap Market as an indicator for
that the five-year fixed rate uh today
and then look at the five the markets
estimate of what the five-year fixed
rate will be in five years time I'm
sorry it gets a little
technical imparts here but that's
actually suggesting that rates will be
1.75 percent lower
in five years time than they are today
so that indicates that up across and
down uh movement
it's just just a question of
which is the the view of the economist
they
they've all got the central thesis here
but the the issue as to whether it's
overdone when I when I look at some of
the data
I look at the PPI data the um producer
price index which has fallen rapidly but
the Consumer Price Index is struggling
to fall but it usually does it just lags
and so it would then play into the
expectations of
maybe and the hope of the governor and
the and the treasury that the inflation
figures will come down quite sharply
from here
I think if that does and I think the
market has become quite skeptical of
believing whether the whether this will
happen but if that does
then I think the market will start to
look at this overdoing the interest rate
expectations but that has to happen
because they it clearly hasn't happened
yet but if it follows the path of PPI
converting into CPI then that is
inevitable but it's the kind of second
half of this year and more into next
thank you Anne-Marie and then I think
Andrea Anne-Marie uh thank you Mr
tarrington vitalet I think what you say
consistently in answer to our questions
is the problem is the market is
shrinking and therefore we don't have
enough properties effectively available
to rent consequence of which is
inevitably rent goes up
what might the government do differently
uh do you think it was a bit of an own
goal to change the tax regime so that
those in that sector as landlords are
effectively
um paying now uh not non-profit but on
turnover do you think if there was a
change there that will make a difference
given that we can't suddenly create the
new houses and build them overnight
which clearly would be a much more
socially acceptable uh answer would that
be a way forward and what do you think
the impact of the renters Reform Bill
has been on this Market
okay so the first thing about about the
tax changes
um
they came in they were announced in 2015
and then were phased in over a number of
years uh and I think for some landlords
it has the effect as I think I said
earlier of being taxed on Revenue not
profit and the consequence of that is
that despite the fact that you could
have
um a kind of a theoretical
profit you're actually paying more tax
than you are earning
um which is which is a strange situation
for people to be in
uh I also think the three percent uh
stamp Duty surcharge acts as a
disincentive so both of these are
disincentives
and they compound with the additional
costs that have come into the sector
I'm less concerned because I think it's
good that the standards in the sector
are are lifted you know we all support
the raising of standards in the private
rented sector and we've been very
supportive of the renters Reform Bill in
fact we we did engage with
um the uh the department of leveling up
uh as that was being converted into uh a
bill
uh on that I think that as I said we're
very supportive we're supportive of the
changes to section 21 it was eight uh
the thing there's two things in there
that we think we are still concerned
about one is on the court process
um you know if you want to sort of go
through an eviction process you have to
go now under the under the bill go to
court
the the government have promised that
they will change the court process to
deal with this but we already know that
the court process is already quite full
and I'm therefore nervous that whether
there will be enough capacity and and to
ensure that it won't overload the court
process and you end up with you know
massive problems that then go that
happen as a consequence the second is
actually going back to the student
Market
um at the moment if any of you have gone
through the process of having a a child
at University
the the the they want to look up their
the following years uh residents
but long way in advance up to a year in
advance
and for a landlord that's great because
they then get a commitment 12 months
forward under the the current bill for
the renters Reform Bill it it means that
the current tenants only have to give
two months notice
and if that's two months before the end
of the final term so maybe April May
then that's not long enough for a for a
landlord to find a tenant for the
following year and in which case they
can't Market their property as being
available so they might find themselves
as being without a tenant
and then suddenly there's a almost like
a free-for-all for students trying to
find property right at the end of the
end of the term so we have discussed it
with them they have acknowledged that
this may need to be reconsidered but uh
it's a very real issue that needs to be
resolved before it converts into an act
thank you Emily Andrea yes thank you
just coming back to Consumers once more
in a previous hearing Charlie Bean said
to us that he thought that um the idea
that
um the pain of rising interest rates
would be taking a longer time to come
through because so many people are on
fixed rate mortgages now he had a
slightly alternative view which was that
um in fact people will plan ahead so it
will affect even if you're your fixed
rate mortgage doesn't expire for two
three years hence it will still affect
your day-to-day spending I know you said
Mr Assam that you're actually contacting
customers six months before their
mortgage ends but I just wonder if any
of you have a view on that is he right
are you already seeing changes in
Behavior or are people going to think
well I just really hope that interest
rates will come down
I think I'll answer some of that I think
it's difficult to know to predict the
future but I think that what we're
seeing anecdotally is customers
overpaying more overpaying so already
starting to look forward and think
actually my deal is coming up in maybe
12 months time it would be better for me
if I have you know some some savings to
be able to pay down my mortgage so we're
definitely seeing that I think the
conversations we're having with
customers or we know that the
conversation of having customers
customers are thinking about that so you
know we talk about how the customers ask
they've got two years left on the deal
what what's their options I think
customers are thinking I'm not sure
we've yet got the evidence to see what
they're acting on but I think customers
are definitely thinking about like we're
having those conversations customers are
concerned about what borrowing costs
might be in the future
um
thank you very much and thanks to our
Witnesses it's been a very interesting
session and I know there's a high level
of interest from our constituents in the
evidence that you've given today and I
think it's fair to say that all of us
MPS uh you know in addition to our
register of interests you know we a lot
of us are paying mortgages and I just
wondered if any of my colleagues after
today's evidence session feel that going
beyond the register of Interest or
anything that they want to draw
attention to in their evidence and make
any statements about any interest they
may have well just for the record I have
a mortgage
um with my husband and my husband and
adult children have a small buy to let
business
yeah
so as you can see it's something that
really touches on uh so many people
we've been very grateful for your
evidence today I think one of the things
that surprised me about your evidence is
that you do sound quite calm about the
quality of your book of mortgages and
how your customers are really
prioritizing everything in terms of
making sure that they pay their
mortgages and that you're not seeing a
particularly marked uh spike in arrear
so it's been a very interesting and
timely session we're very appreciative
uh to you all for your time and at this
point I'm going to say order order that
concludes this treasury committee
session thank you